oh you got a man it's just over what
happened
hold on just a second
let's talk about it what happened how
long did y'all take
10 years God damn
oh [__] oh it just happened
hey she been crying about this [__] for
months just single you're out here huh
oh that was painful
apparently she don't want to be single
oh my God Ain't It Funny When someone
tells me their heart is broken in one
word that's not supposed to be a
heartbroken word you know why I'm able
to laugh is because I know you're going
to be okay just so you know that if no
no you're not yet but you will be okay
we're not gonna lie to each other we're
honest people I told you I cried today
you can't be honest with me then
there you go did you make okay it's all
good
nobody talking this much is okay